what's up guys with iPhone 14 plus this
thing has six gigs of RAM and the a15
chip inside of it and we're going to run
some games on it gen chin Call of Duty
Diablo Moto Apex Legends and an apple
arcade game gear Club at the end before
we start temperature checks
so the back right now is about 39
degrees 30 degrees ish 31
you know
not too bad
on the front
yeah
yeah it's not too bad and also with 86
battery so let's just see how much these
games trained it out this video was shot
in 120 FPS so you guys can see every
frame rate drop as it happens so let's
just get into it
oh okay not a good start
well I guess combat first and then we go
to Monster later on
but yes
all right uh before we continue this
fight let's just quickly check our
settings
all right so Graphics wise we actually
have set everything to the highest and
run 860 FPS so so far it's not
performing terribly
and we're doing just fine
oh yeah I didn't respect my life
beautiful but never mind
yeah I don't I don't seem to see any
kind of like terrorism
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
jobs on my end if you see anything just
leave a comment and maybe like And
subscribe to this video and to our
Channel
so don't be sick but let's move on to
monster and see what we have all right
before we get into the monster check
let's do a temperature check because
it's kind of feeling warm at the bottom
down here
37 38 around almost done there yep
it's all about here
that's probably where the chip was at
ish
I checked the back
[Applause]
onwards we have work to do
35-ish right here it gets really hot
down here yeah 38 39 almost 40 around
this area so that's where the chips at
so
I think the rest of it's fine you know
but it's just this one spot here but
that's to be expected because it's you
know it's Kenshin but yeah let's just
see how it performs in a crowded area
[Music]
I'm not really pick up anything
[Applause]
honestly
it's not that bad I'd say so far you
know I haven't really noticed any like
major frame rate drops or anything so
it's actually holding up pretty well
okay let's go in like so I didn't change
my party I'm gonna go there
but yeah before we enter the spiral bits
we are currently at
uh 86 still wow and temperature wise
it's at 43 now and it's actually getting
really hot around along the sides here
it is hella hot
43 42 yeah it's this whole phone's
really heating up
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
hear me
so let's play
and yeah that's it
man I should do everything right and
let's see how much patch we have after
this whole play session it's about six I
think we're 15 10 minutes ish uh without
the 85 so that's pretty all right and
the high settings and
temperature wise
I'd say temperatures have actually
cooled down
yeah they have cooled down quite a bit
actually from the 45 or 44 that was here
just now it's like 41 40 now songs is
doing pretty all right I mean always
because it's open more so it'll take
more RAM and what not to process the
graphics but yeah I actually cooled down
quite a bit so yeah so yeah genshing on
the iPhone 14 plus is definitely yes
so let's just move on to Apex Legends
this video is brought to you by MSI meat
during the latest 12th gen Intel Core i7
processor RTX 30 series graphics and a
16 inch Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge it lets you
unleash maximum productivity with up to
11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the summit e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime
all right so let's check the settings
real quick
settings and graphics and audio uh Ultra
frame rate extreme HD graphics quality
everything else is turned on and high
and high so we're doing pretty good and
let's just get into a game
[Applause]
oh wow so far
pretty well it feels really smooth
[Music]
[Applause]
the doc will keep on Reviving you even
if I have to go
[Applause]
the beginning
[Applause]
okay this one though but so far even
after all the engagements not too bad
heating up just a little bit but we'll
check that out in a bit so yeah
[Applause]
shooting at me
let's see these guys
that makes place hopelessly
okay so before that let's just check the
temperature
37 38.
39 ish
but it doesn't feel like comfortable but
it's not hard part like engine oh there
got company and they're not here to send
me chickens shooting contact with Target
[Applause]
so honestly after all those engagements
and I think I think it's safe to say
that Apex runs pretty damn well on the
iPhone 14 plus and let's just do a final
temperature check before more than the
next game
and the front is doing about 39 32 the
eight on there on the bottom here it's
quite hot it's like 42. this is where
the chipset
yes it does feel it will get a little
bit uncomfortable down here after a
while but that's a given let's check the
bag itself
on here
42 43 39 38 around there
yeah it's honestly all approaching about
four people the bottom here so honestly
it's
shout out it's not that bad
[Music]
but yeah other than that this thing runs
with you all
trying to figure out where they're at
and yeah oh
come get this kill let's move the next
game
yeah
right before we get into the next game
we are at 79 right now and let's just do
a temperature check before we get in
just one more so what's double 40
running hot from Apex and genshin
on the same run
and
you know it's still a bit hot you know
I may want to let it cool down a bit
just because it does get uncomfortable
playing with it on the sides here
especially because like you know these
are very big games and they take up a
lot of memory and GPU usage sort of
things it will get hot so let's just
after this I'm gonna let it cool down
for a bit so that it's comfortable for
me to play on but other than that here
are the temperature results on this
thing
down the sides just because
it does get a bit hot
35 degrees on the sides
especially this side because that's
where the chips at
still about 35 huh so oh 37 I see 37
right there
thereabouts
yes
so yeah it will heat up on the sides
here especially these sides so like
obviously if you're going to be getting
one of these phones you might want to
get a case as well so that's one of the
Call of Duty once this thing has cooled
down a little bit
all right now that it's rested a little
bit let's just check the temperature
again as I think before the sides do
heat up together with the rest of the
back and I think the whole phone
actually so let's just check the
temperature
so everything's back to its base I mean
it's a lot cooler now because we are in
an air-conditioned environment so take
note of that
uh sides are 28 26 everything's
basically below 30
including the back
so yes a bit cool to the touch but
nonetheless comfortable to play with so
let's move on to the next game uh Call
of Duty
all right since we're in
major Tomoka looks really good on the
front page but let's check the settings
again like I said I have set up
everything prior to playing the games so
everything very high and the thing about
frame rate is it's on very high as well
everything is great multiplayer let's
just turn everything on and we're good
yeah
so let's just get into a game
all right let's go
sound is solid with HD audio pack
okay that's gonna do
all right first Blood that's cool
[Applause]
oh on the side
yeah so far it's very smooth
oh sneaky fellow
he's still up there oh it's not
someone else
no down down down and my aim being
terrible
but other than that it runs very smooth
and honestly no complaints
just hunt this guy on top
years
let's die forever
[Applause]
then camper it's called doggy
and my dog Zone but yeah no fury drops
you know it's playing very smooth I'm
actually having fun with this
video
there we go
there we go
[Applause]
oh
timer there we go nice after death
kill but yeah it handles off pretty well
not it's not heating up at all
so starting with where the chip is at
roughly yeah it's all good everything is
very comfortable let's check the back uh
roughly where the chip is at and
honestly the temperature is actually
pretty okay I think they're lower than
what we initially started off with so
yeah that's that's Call of Duty let's
move on to Diablo Immortal all the way
here
let's check the settings real quick
Graphics 60 yes Ultra oh it doesn't
support Ultra on high yeah sure why not
everything else is on very high so and
we did PVP effects now are we not really
much PVP more PVE so let's just move on
and play the game go around and just
fight some demons and zombies and
whatever
see how the schools
I mean so far there isn't much of an
issue with all the other games
grab all that looks like we have a chest
over here some reflection
that will experience
and steam all everyone
it's my Elite and their Community is
closed but yeah most favorite jobs than
anything I mean
nope yep
okay
but yes
it's doing very well
lots of enemies lots of fighting lots of
Graphics lots of units on the ground
we're doing fine
oh nice
let's move now
okay
nice it's great honestly it feels good
the phone isn't hot at all that's still
a quick temperature check
and yeah 33 35 around here
everything is pretty much chill honestly
the sides aren't heating up as much the
back
honestly showing about the same sounds
so we are all good and in the clear
Diablo mobile is a goal on the iPhone 14
plus all right let's move to the last
game which is a Apple arcade here right
next game uh before we get into this we
are currently at
see 71 like I said before
and then temperature check need to
decrease the brightness just a little
bit
slow
and then check temperature
yep everything is still pretty much
Dandy it's all good
yep you're in the clear 35 inch in the
back where the chip is at we are all
good and let's just play gear Club
all right we are in gear club before we
start let's just check the settings and
I don't think there's anything much here
but yeah uh
KPS to mph doesn't really matter to me
power savings on and off uh that's
that's that's about it you can't really
change the settings because like Anyway
everything's optimized for the iPhone so
yeah just download and play
see how this goes
I am not much of a racing driver so
forgive me if I start crashing the
people for fun
oh
oh okay
foreign
[Music]
jobs nothing everything plays pretty
smooth you can tell from the
inputs I'm putting like as I'm tapping I
think it's really moving the direction
pretty well
hey
all right doing good so far phone is
definitely not heating up
feel very cool to the touch
and I've obviously I lost that but it's
all good
race Everything feels pretty smooth and
let's just check the temperature real
quick honestly which I don't think it
would have changed as much
yeah still about 32 39 ish
honestly very very low it's very
comfortable to play with so let's just
move on to final thoughts for the iPhone
14 plus having played the iPhone 14 plus
throughout this video I'd say that it's
definitely worth considering because
it's literally just A14 that's the size
of a pro Max and it's great for me
because my hands are huge as you guys
have said and this thing has given more
real estate to play around and navigate
my UI so not much of a problem I'm quite
surprised with how well this is managed
heat compared to other iPhones I guess
because I mean it is using a15 chip and
given how download games are there
that's really been optimized for the a15
compared to a16 you know we're obviously
going to see a lot better CPU and GPU
management if you guys like this video
make sure to like And subscribe to us
and if you love this kind of content
check this out